[Music]
my guest this week is an author and
columnist who's written for the New York
Times and Wall Street Journal and is a
regular contributor to reason and my
hometown newspaper Newsday at the young
welcome to the Rubin report it's great
to be here I am very delighted that was
your hometown that is I am a Long
Islander I born in Brooklyn grew up in
Long Island with the New York City my
whole life now here I am in LA okay
you're a Jersey girl though right I am
well I'm originally from Russia yeah
we're gonna do that but I have been a
Jersey girl since 1981 so it has
actually been a while oh that sounds
like a book right there from Jersey from
Russia to join Russia to Jersey well I
didn't write a book called growing up in
Moscow which was my first book young out
an 89 when I was fresh out of college so
yeah well that's exactly where I want to
start - all right so well done okay so
in my direct message I talked a bit
about Russia and I have a sense that in
the next month or so we're gonna be
hearing a lot more about Russia between
what's going on in Syria people you know
talking about the WikiLeaks stuff and is
there somehow a connection that they
want to take down Hillary does right
does Trump have business ties to Russia
all of this stuff so let's go back to
your first 16 years what was it like
growing up in Russia and if you don't
want to give me your exact age give me a
rough estimate of the years I was born
in 1965 okay yeah all right so let's
talk about talk about growing up in
Russia yeah I was growing up in the
Fresno years and it was interesting
because at the time it really seemed
like the regime that existed at the time
was really forever and it was funny
because there was a book by a Russian
dissident named Andre amaura called will
the Soviet Union exist until 1984
and he picked that date because of war
well of course right and it's so bizarre
because at the time I heard about this
book you know my father was a kind of
well both my parents were really kind of
closeted dissidents
and we had bad literature on the house
what was banned what type of literature
was actually banned Oh anything that was
critical of of the Soviet system
Solzhenitsyn of course the works of
dissidents there were others who were
not even really formally banned but kind
of really frowned upon from the early
years of the Soviet regime like people
who were executed for being sort of an
opposition war well of course was burned
I didn't actually get to read it well
until I had left the Soviet Union right
and it's interesting because a number of
people who read or well yeah it was
called samizdat you know these
typewritten leaflets that were kind of
passed around from person to person
underground right people who read world
well who read horrible answers smuggled
in foreign editions a lot of people in
the Soviet Union really were shocked to
learn that Orwell had never actually
been to the Soviet Union some of them
were sure that were well like George
Orwell must have been like they're done
named for a Russian emigre because who
else could have understood this because
the pressure of the pressure to conform
to the dominant ideology yeah so anyway
yeah so Andrea Marek I picked that date
because of the book 1984 of course and
at the time when I first heard about it
I think no one could really imagine that
this would sort of come true because it
actually didn't exist that long past
1984 you know he was off by seven years
yeah that's pretty good really like when
I was growing up no one really could
have imagined that and I think that's
kind of a useful thing to keep in mind
when we think of today's events and the
son stack you know we really have no
idea whatsoever what the world is going
to look like in five six seven years
yeah things are real
unpredictable they really are in that
that's why I did the direct message they
I did because I want people to have some
knowledge about some of this stuff so
that so that the sector we start hearing
about this land or we're not all caught
off guard and have no kind but in terms
of what it was like to grow up in in the
Soviet Union and it's really difficult
to answer on one word because you know
it was in many ways it was a complex
society it was not the same as it was in
a Stalin era where you know it really
was kind of back down the height of
totalitarianism when you know very
little information or content as we
would say today was allowed to kind of
seep in that was not thoroughly filtered
through the official ideology like at
the time for instance back in the 30s
and even 50s
Dostoevsky was bad maybe not again not
officially banned but very difficult to
get and certainly wasn't studied in
schools and colleges by the time that I
was in high school in Russia we actually
had a prime minister on the curriculum
you know we were the things that
mentioned religion were kind of allowed
again anything that really was not very
overtly critical all the Soviet Union
was okay like well dr. Zhivago France
right but I did have the experience of
growing up in a situation where when I
was maybe seven or eight years old but I
started going to school and I started
coming home and saying oh well we live
in the best country in the world because
we have communism that was when my
parents decided that they kind of had to
explain to me that you know not really
very good they hand you some of those
leaflets that were going around at the
age of seven but they just kind of talk
to me and kind of gave me a little bit
of an explanation of what was what and
and I remember very well my mother
telling me you know you really you
cannot tell anyone at school what we
talked about it though
because otherwise you know we'll go to
jail and I'm not even sure that they
would have because again at the time you
know things were a little more flexible
and open that they used to be I actually
know of a situation friends of my
parents that their son started talking
in kindergarten about how you know his
dad was saying that Lenin was really not
the greatest person who ever lived
but actually is one of the teachers one
of the kindergarten teachers called
Anna's mom and said and basically said
you know what I don't really care what
you talk about at home but you know
please don't do it in front of the kid
because you don't know who else is gonna
tell us she was that was a pretty a
pretty enlightened man for the teachers
yeah but Sammy in the society there was
a lot of kind of flexibility under the
radar so to speak but officially it was
all very conformist you know we had to
at school we had to attend these
mandatory meetings where everyone had to
kind of repeat the slogans and you know
sing the praises of the Soviet Union and
this is actually one reason that a lot
of the stuff that is going on today and
American universities really resonates
with me because you know I've been
saying to my mom my dad passed away two
years ago unfortunately but I've been
saying to my mom you know this really
feels like the Soviet Union where they
heard you into these you know meetings
where you have to sit there and say all
the right things and it's not just that
you're not allowed to say you know
things you're not allowed to say is that
it's that you have to say the things
you're supposed to say yeah which is
yeah well as I'm listening you know I
absolutely see that through-line I'm not
saying because you know we're not no one
gets hurt in to the gulag you know their
resin because I mean again when I was
growing up I didn't know that you could
you know it wasn't very likely maybe but
you could go to prison for
you know saying heretical things but you
know we are kind of getting to the point
in many areas of society where you can
lose your job yeah you know for for
saying the wrong thing ideologically
which you know in the Soviet Union in
the 1970s that actually losing your job
was a much more likely outcome than I'm
going to present like unless you were
actually like politically active as a
dissident right it's interesting because
I find that I used to give anonymous
people online more crap
for anonymous a lot of people would
respond and say you know I don't want to
lose my job or anything yeah I don't
know that there's a lot of instances of
that in the United States but it's more
about that chilling effect which is sort
of what you're talking about existed
right all the time right so your parents
never went to jail but they don't really
talk about this it's not all that so so
16 years old you move here was it
because you realize that there was this
great opportunity when they started
releasing Soviet Jews in the 70s and my
dad had actually talked for several
years about leaving my mom was a little
more uncertain about it she had a job
that she really loved she was teaching
at one is she's a music teacher and she
actually still teaches but she was
teaching at one of the top music schools
in Moscow and you know she had students
that she was very attached to and she
just really felt and it was funny
because she felt that she would never
find that kind of work in the US and she
actually ended up doing pretty well I
think so yeah but says she was a little
hesitant and and it was also just sort
of the general uncertainty you know
moving to a whole new country learning a
new language III went to a school that
specialized in English by the way I
started learning English when I was
about seven and it wasn't really at the
time with a view to going to America
eventually it was just because I mean
the it was a better school that most and
it was I think because of English there
was also more exposure to you
materials that you wouldn't normally see
on a curriculum and so on so you know
for me it was really at least in terms
of language it wasn't quite as
intimidating my parents really did have
to kind of start all over again yeah so
yeah yeah finally I think my my parents
both felt that things were getting worse
toward the end of the 70s and at the
time again no one knew what was going to
happen yeah a lot of people thought that
there was going to be a kind of
resurgence of Stalinist type uh you know
really harsh brutal dictatorship yeah uh
where you couldn't go to prison very
easily for saying the wrong thing yeah
yeah and but at that point you were you
were allowed to just pick up and leave
your parents were allowed to just say
okay we're leaving now not just well no
no it certainly wasn't that simple I
mean you had to apply for permission to
leave it was it was not for anyone it
was basically limited to Soviet Jews who
were officially being allowed to leave
for like repatriation to Israel and
their family reunification and I don't
really like the Jews but they weren't
letting the Jews leave does that pretty
much the anti-semitism that was another
thing the anti-semitism was growing much
more noticeable it was getting to be
very difficult for young Jewish people
to get into college
you know we my parents personally knew
situations where you know kids who were
extremely good students were basically
blocked ball during the admission exams
and and it was this completely closed
system where they didn't have to tell
you like where you had failed on the
exams
yeah and the it was really really easy
to kind of kill you if they wanted to
especially since what part of the
entrance exam by the way was
marxism-leninism
and if they could quiz here you had to
write on his tux of you know the plenary
session of the Communist Party in 1956
really and then they could quiz you on
the stuff and you know and and it was
really good and if they wanted to fail
you it was just really easy to do that
yeah so you know and I think that was
there was another reason that prompted
my parents to finally decide to leave
but yeah well fishel II we were
emigrating to reunite with my father's
aunt in Israel yeah and and then you
would have it was the whole thing kind
of existed under jackson-vanik it was
kind of an arrangement where the United
States where you know Russia was where
the Soviet Union at the time was getting
kind of benefits and trade with the u.s.
in exchange for allowing Soviet Jews to
leave yeah and I think there were a few
other groups like Pentecostal Christians
who were kind of a very persecuted
sucked we're also part of that but
mainly it was Soviet Jews so yeah once
you once you actually left the Soviet
Union done you got to Vienna as a way
station and then you got a choice of did
you want to go to Israel or did you want
to go to it yes so you told them or they
were under the impression you were going
to Israel but then you went to the
United States uh I think they kind of
knew or they sorta yeah I think they
knew what was going on because I think
at the time like by the time that we
were leaving I think about 80% of the
Soviet Jews who were emigrating we're
actually going to the United States so
what they didn't really care so what was
it like you you sort of had the benefit
of as you said speaking English at an
early age and going to school what was
it like go to move to Jersey 16 and and
that actually was my very first so whoa
okay yeah and this is funny my I
actually worked for about six months
before my parents eventually found work
in Jersey and that was why we ended up
moving
but for a while I was the main
breadwinner because I was the person
with English and I had a job as a
secretary with the Boy Scouts of America
New York Chapter yeah because I also I
knew how to type and I I knew how to
type in Russian but I rented a
typewriter and English keyboard
typewriter and took me about a week to
you know relearn how to type in English
and what was that like I mean you go
from Russia
now you're the breadwinner for your
parents in this new country learning a
new job and all that I mean how did that
feel oh actually felt really excited ya
know that whole period of my life was
actually quite exciting because you know
just the mirror experience of going
abroad you know and my father actually
had travelled a bit because he was a
musician he had traveled with the Moscow
Symphony Orchestra he was actually
mainly he was a sound producer for for
the radio but he was also a violinist
and he did occasionally get the trouble
he goes yeah he had some interesting
experiences too he was actually in
England in 1968 when the Soviet Union
invaded Czechoslovakia and he would have
defected for sure if you didn't have a
family back home and my mom actually
wasn't even sure that he was coming dog
because when she heard about the
invasion and she was like oh my god
you know but nobody showed up at the
door and everybody but but he I I think
he was very very tempted and I mean and
yeah I don't think he was tempted to
actually do it because he but he did say
you know that if it wasn't for God you
know he probably would have made that
decision because it was just and you
know they had the experience of you know
being sort of booed by the audience of
London
yeah it was just really yeah really
trying
so let's yeah there's so much that we
yeah yeah we could go on there's so much
I can do about just the history and and
being an immigrant but for me it was
really exciting because first of all it
was this whole world of information that
had opened up to me like you know
reading were well yeah and and I
remember I just the experience and I
actually still remember this
I remember when when we came here you
know I opened I think I'm most in York
Post and this was this was shortly
before Reagan was elected so you know I
open the New York Post and I see this
really mean cartoon of Jimmy Carter and
I was like here is the question you know
basically detection as I complete it
right I mean I love that I love that
because it's so obviously framed so much
of what you write about yeah and and
that was just an amazing and I just
suddenly I mean I still remember dad
because it was this moment that really
crystallized you know the fact of being
in a free country that you can actually
do this yeah and well I want to talk
about some of that I want to talk about
some of the issues of being in a free
country but let's do one let's do one
other thing on Russia first because I
mentioned some stuff about Russia up top
what do you make of just generally
what's happening with Russia now just
let's spend a couple minutes on that
that Putin is really trying to fill this
void that America seems to be leaving in
the world what what is going on in Syria
have they officially taken Ukraine give
me the state of Russia I thought you
know Putin definitely ever since he came
to power it's been increasingly clear
that I think he wants to you know
rebuild a Russia as a superpower it
can't really return to what
the Soviet Union was although I'm not
really sure he understands that yeah I
mean I might be why he took Ukraine
right or took Crimea yeah yeah I don't I
mean there is this view that Putin is
sort of superhuman Lee clever
he's great strategist I'm not really
sure that's the case because you know
actually uh arguably he could have
gotten further in with Ukraine if he had
just maintained a you know tried to
maintain a friendly relationship with
and then you know trade and so on
you know without actually trying to
force you know his person and I don't
want to say his puppet because yeah I'm
not even really sure that the president
who was who was removed was completely a
puppet of the Kremlin but he was
definitely sort of Putin's man and I
think he in a way kind of overplayed his
hand in Ukraine I mean right now he's in
a situation where he's much better at
kind of messing things up for other
countries than he is you know actually
doing something good for Russia right
because right now for instance the
situation with Ukraine is that yeah I
mean the the new government in Ukraine
is not really able to push through you
know wrote the reforms that once partly
because it's bogged down in this endless
kind of undeclared worry that's going on
in these regions and you know they've
got Putin breathing down their neck
basically but at the same time Russia is
also blog down in this undeclared war
and it can really a lot of the stuff can
kind of come back and bite both Russia
because they're creating this kind of
quasi mercenary army of you know armed
people who have the experience now of
fighting and this guerrilla war and who
knows what will happen when these people
are told well we don't need you anymore
because we're kind of done with this so
I think this could create a lot of deist
in Russia itself he and I could go on
and on about those because he's also his
God he's kind of got a tiger by the tail
and Chechnya because basically he made a
deal with us guy Ramzan Kadyrov of well
he basically like you make sure Church
now stays a Russian province and you
know you make sure that Putin gets 100
percent of the votes in Chechnya
elections which I think he does and you
know you make sure that you know we get
a cut of the will profits and exchanging
you you can really do anything you want
yes so and this is actually kind of
interesting because I know that there
are people on the right in the West who
see Putin has this kind of bulwark of
the thumbs against Sharia law mhm
under Putin's leadership there is a part
of the Russian Federation that is
basically a Sharia State really what
just judge now yeah and not many people
know about this I didn't know that yeah
well it actually is it's you know women
are forced to wear veils you know this
is a guy who's actually spoken out in
favor of polygamy you know which is
technically illegal under Russian law
and you know and there are people who've
said like wait a minute you know this
guy is the president of a you know
Republic that is part of the Russian
Federation what is he doing really
advocating things that are contrary to
the Russian Constitution and of course
who really carries because you know the
law currently is he just wants the votes
to keep him partying Federation but then
lets them know so this guy is a Coderre
of is is a very very strong Putin
supporter like he if necessary he will
bring out his troops that are loyal to
him you know to fight I mean I it's
pretty well known that he sent people to
eastern Ukraine to to fight them the
gorillas were there so yeah but at the
same time it is kind of a tiger by the
tail situation because if suddenly it
becomes advantageous for Coderre of the
turn important you know who know
was gonna happen and he's he's a pretty
dangerous guy you know he's he's kind of
the classic warlord who was you know God
has people who are extremely loyal to
him you know so it's I don't think Putin
is quite as smart as his often given
credit for I think a lot of the time
when he's succeeded it's mainly because
of the failures of the West because you
know he as he said he's he's good at
stepping into the vacuum that arises
when for instance American leadership
kind of pulls bad yeah so that's the
perfect segue of course to everything
that's going right in Syria what is he
trying to accomplish in Syria is he
really trying to keep Assad in power
yeah yeah yeah I think part of that is
really just a signal that you know he
stands behind us allies and yeah he's
ostensibly making noises about you know
creating the preconditions for you know
Assad to talk to talk to the opposition
but you know given the way that Putin
treats the opposition and Russia right I
mean okay he doesn't carpet bombs I mean
you know but but that's really you know
other than that he's really not a
talking to the opposition guy right he
isn't more of a you know kill the
opposition quietly aware you know put
them in jail or you know basically leave
them with no institutional support
whatsoever guy and you know we we I
think it's really fairly clear that you
know the the murder of Boris Nemtsov who
was a four at one point a really popular
governor who later became part of the
opposition and you know who I think who
had the charisma really to to appeal to
people I don't know that he actually was
directly a threat to Putin but you know
but even so it's fairly clear that there
was some kind of official handy and his
murder right so I mean I think that kind
of tells you a lot about you know how
puts and feels about dealing with the
arrest so basically the idea
I think I'm backing my guy it's probably
good for the economy at some level right
yeah yeah exactly and I think it's good
for kind of maintaining his strongman
image both inside and outside Russia
Putin I very clearly kind of has an
affinity with dictators he gets pretty
upset at regime change anywhere you know
he was from I've heard stories and again
you know these are sort of rumors from
people who are who have been on the
inside but I've heard that he was
extremely upset but but what happened to
Qaddafi and you really took that
personally right like he took it
personally and I think he part of his
issues with the United States and I
think it goes back to it rock and a few
other things but he really does see the
United States as you know promoting
regime change around the world and and I
think that's part of this beef with the
u.s. yeah so is that the irony of where
we're at at the moment that it seems to
me that the Democrats and Hillary are
more anti Russia than the Republicans at
the moment now maybe Trump has business
ties there it's very early but Hillary
Hillary was for going in and toppling
Qaddafi and apparently now it came out
that a lot of the leaders of the army
we're saying don't do it so so there is
some legitimacy to Putin's fears I
suppose if you're Putin you can
understand yeah well I wouldn't we'll
look at and I don't really want to get
into the whole Middle East situation
yeah yeah I understand the kind of anti
interventionist argument I think we've
definitely overextend ourselves and you
know doing things around the world that
get us into really messy situations
the same time I'm a little skeptical of
this whole kind of line of argument that
oh well we've made such a mess every
there is this assumption that if only it
weren't for our introduction like
everything would be you know peaceful
and quiet I don't think that's
necessarily the case and I think that in
a way it's funny because it kind of
parallels a lot of the left-wing
arguments about foreign policy like the
other day I saw somebody on Twitter and
I don't I'm not even sure why this came
up but for some reason they were talking
about how oh well it was really Nick
Singh who was responsible for the
genocide in Cambodia
I mean I'm sorry but you know it's this
mindset that somehow the West is behind
everything bad that happens in
non-western countries and I think it's
again kind of ironic that we're seeing
the same kind of mindset on their on the
anti introduction astride today and
again this is not to say that you know
mistakes haven't been made so right but
it really doesn't mean that you know if
we if we hadn't blundered in Libya and
in Iraq and so on that that region today
would be just you know a model of peace
and quiet I don't think we have no idea
by the way what would have happened we
don't but we do know that actually Iraq
was better and they were having
basically free elections and then we
left George W Bush had signed the thing
to leave but Obama is the right there's
collective responsibility for this I
think you know leaving aside the merits
of the invasion itself I think it's
pretty clear that the administration in
Iraq post invasion was very badly
mismanaged yeah and I think that was
part of why I think they weren't able to
get a deal that would have allowed us to
keep some troops there but but I think
what you're saying is that not
everything all the time it's raise
America's well no it's not and it's
really whether you're blaming George W
Bush or whether
Hillary and Obama you know it's really
much much more complicated than that
there are forces and it's kind of ironic
because in a way in a ways demeaning
really to the people in those countries
to say that oh well everything they do
is really only because of instigation
and so forth right that they only they
have their own extremely complicated
history and you know they do things for
their own reasons I mean obviously we
contribute for a better or for worse but
it's it's really an oversimplification
to say that oh well and a lot of
conservatives already saying that no oh
well Hillary started this mess in the
Middle East even really want to go there
[Music]
you